A large part of Kaiser's success is because it's concentrated in
a few areas where it has the market presence to own and operate all,
or most of its facilities and employ its physicians.
Can smaller care organizations deliver the kind of care that Kaiser provides?
Many feel the patient-centered medical home,
or PCMH, provides for this.
The concept dates to the early 1960s.
In fact, I worked in an early example of the PCMH,
where I oversaw the development of one of
the first electronic medical records systems starting around 1970.
The PCMH model is advocated by the American College of Physicians,
or ACP, which is the professional organization for internal medicine doctors.
It's also supported by the American Academy of Family Physicians,
or AAFP, the other large professional association of primary care physicians.
This is because their members are the doctors on
the front lines of managing chronic disease.
The ACP describes the PCMH as,
"A care delivery model whereby patient treatment is coordinated through
their primary care physician to ensure they
receive the necessary care when and where they need it,
in a manner they can understand."
The objective is to have a centralized setting that facilitates
partnerships between individual patients and their personal physicians,
and when appropriate, for patients' family.
Care is facilitated by registries,
information technology, health information exchange,
and other means to assure that patients get the indicated care,
when and where they need and want it
in a culturally and linguistically appropriate manner.
Note again, in this graphic from the AAFP,
the emphasis is on providing all needed
care and using information technology to manage that.